SHOULD BE INTERESTING TO TERRIT
FIRST TIME IN SCORE.
>>Chris: THIS IS BOTH GODOWN KR
THE WIN
IT IS DEFLECTED
TO THE
POWER-PLAY GOALS.
FORSOWDER GETTING LOOSE AND
GOT A
>>Willy: FOX DIALED FROM LONG
DISTANCE TO SEE IF SAROS HAD IT
MOMENT.  PASSEDATORS HAVE 22 SH
TO THE
STILL TIME MADE
IN.
>>Chris: THAT IS HUGE FROM RAC
TOMASINO AND  IN
ONLY A SECOND NHL GAMEEROUS OUTH
LOOK AT THE NISSAN DEFENSIVE
STOP
ONE IN FRONT.
>>ChJOSI QUICKLY MOVES IT
TO
MINUTE.
GREAT RECOVERY BY THE RANGERS,
TWO NEW
BODIES OUT THERE.
>>Chris: DUCHENE WAS READY
FORSBERG BACK.
QUICON
THE TRANSITION I THINK JOSI
WANTED TO GET MAKE
BUYING SHOOTING LANES AND
PASSING LALA
MINUTE TO PLAY IN THE
2nd  PERIOD.
GREAT GRAHAM FORSBERG OVER
DIFFERENTIAL
BETTER POSSESSION EDGE IN THE
FIRST THREE GAMES.
TO WINNIPEG
ON MINNESOTA MINNESOTA ON
SUNDAY FIRST BACK TO BACK FIRST
ROAD GAMES.  A TOUGH CHALLENGIN
QUICK SO WE WILLPERIOD, KEEP IT
CALLSTHEY ARE DOING FOUR
GUYS BACK IN THE NEUTRAL ZONE,
ALIGNMENT  THINK ABOUT
TIME TO MAKE PLAYS YOU GET IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE ICE, TOUGH TO
CREATE
THE LINE, CRATER, LEFT FOR THE
THEIR THIRD